i
uh haven't really figured out this
marriage thing myself so i don't know
what kind of advice he thinks i'm gonna
give to us
kim kardashian is not afraid to crack
jokes at her own expense even when it
comes to her past marriages from
saturday night live i married the best
rapper of all time when i divorced him
you have to know it came down to just
one thing
his personality
to weddings it's honestly so nice to be
here for
a gay wedding i mean i haven't been to
one since my second wedding
kim knows how to get a crowd going i
think you have to have a sense of humor
while delivering a speech during a
celebration ahead of close friend simon
huck's wedding the beauty and fashion
mogul got real about her marriage track
record kim was previously married to
damon thomas and chris humphries and in
february she filed for divorce from
kanye west
i
was a little bit confused because
i
haven't really figured out this marriage
thing myself
so i don't know what kind of advice he
thinks i'm going to give to my team
but kim did share this helpful piece of
advice i will say i
have learned a lot and
i have some tips
for you guys like aesthetically of what
i think is super important because i
think if you get this ready you guys
might have a chance
when you guys are getting married and
the guy is officiating you right when
you're done and you guys are going to
kiss the guy's always in the back of the
picture
or there's a microphone right there so
you kind of have to clear the way
because
it ruins all the pictures
and sometimes that's all you got
now this isn't the first time kim has
publicly poked fun at herself i know i'm
surprised to see me here too
during her hosting gig at snl last month
the mother of four used her monologue to
joke about some of her family's most
memorable moments with all of the k
names it's really impressive that my mom
didn't pick karen i mean somehow she
just knew
i don't know how she saw that one coming
and not caitlyn
she even addressed her split from kanye
he's the richest black man in america a
talented legit genius who gave me four
incredible kids
so when i divorced him you have to know
it came down to just one thing his
personality
but simon's wedding isn't the only one
kim attended last week she was also
there for her lifelong pal paris
hilton's special day
the skim's founder was among paris and
husband carter rooms 250 guests at their
wedding in los angeles here's kim at the
black tie affair posing with some pals
including paris's other bff nicole
ritchie et spoke to the mother of the
bride kathy hilton ahead of the nuptials
and she shared what she was most excited
about friends have come in from all over
the world
from everywhere so just to be in a room
with all the people that we love that
are just so excited
and then there's some entertainment and
i don't know it's a surprise so